[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
closing arguments are presented as an
ex-florida police captain stands trial
for murder and that's what this case is
about
it truly is about a man who killed
another man over a popcorn toss you
can't kill anyone for an f-bomb that's
for sure plus will scott peterson
receive a new trial the latest from a
series of evidentiary hearings and
hopefully this is a step in the right
direction
for people that's in power
to do the right thing a guilty verdict
is returned for the three ex-officers
connected to the death of george floyd
but first hopefully you have seen enough
in this trial
that when you go into the apartments
when you're outside of the building
you'll be able to recognize those things
that you need to recognize we're live in
louisville kentucky outside the
apartment where brianna taylor was shot
and killed law on crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to long crime daily
i'm jesse weber in for brian buckmeyer
who's in kentucky covering the trial
about the death of briana taylor joining
me from new york is co-host terry austin
jurors step outside of the louisville
courtroom on friday and into the
apartment where 26 year old brianna
taylor was shot and killed in march of
2020. ex-louisville officer brett
hankinson is not charged with taylor's
death but instead stands trial for
charges of wanton endangerment for
firing shots through taylor's apartment
into a unit behind hers in march 2020
officers executed a no knock warrant to
taylor's apartment her boyfriend
believing the officers were intruders
fired at them the officers shot back and
taylor was killed in that crossfire that
apartment building is where long crime
daily host brian buckmeyer joins us now
live brian it's good to see you my
understanding is jurors were actually
shown inside the building on friday
correct
yes jesse so the jurors were able to
stand right here where i'm standing now
and actually walk through if you can see
the breezeway here to briana taylor's
apartment now this is the infamous
window this is where our jurors are were
able to see where brett hankinson is
accused of shooting through the window
now they were also able to walk through
this breezeway and into the apartment
now they got through the front door and
then walking through the front door they
walked through the apartment they got to
see the long hallway and this is a long
hallway that they're saying that
kenneth walker shot the officer
john manley unsure as to whether or not
that bullet hit him and then they saw
the large window where they actually saw
that brett hankinson
is said to have shot through that window
and gone through to briana taylor's and
you can see the long corridor then
reaching back to where
briana taylor was shot and killed now as
you get to the back of the apartment
getting a little creative here for our
viewers here you're seeing this is the
back window where the bullets fired out
through the apartment behind brianna
taylor's and then as the jurors were
told went out throughout the night
that's pretty incredible there brian uh
wow so joining us today is co-host terry
austin also legal analyst julie
rendellman julie i want to start with
you what kind of effect can it have on a
jury to be shown at the scene of a crime
is that something that we often see
so we don't often see that um and and
it's a quite unique experience for the
jury and and the reason it's so
important is they get really their own
first-hand look at things that they
never would get to see in the courtroom
they actually get that 3d look now at
the same time there's some questions
that are raised about that the lighting
may be different the atmosphere is
different and so that's something the
jury has to keep in mind when they're
viewing this because it's not in the
same necessary
necessarily condition as it was at the
time the actual alleged crime happened
and that's something they're going to
have to keep in mind terry kind of heard
it from brian we know that the scene of
the crime was absolutely chaotic there
was even some confusion about who
actually shot at the police officers on
that day do you think that issue has
been clarified so far
you know what it has not been clarified
at least in my mind jesse and it's a
point that really isn't going to affect
whether or not hankinson was responsible
here for the dangering of the other
individuals in that second apartment but
i do want that to be clarified we know
that kenneth walker shot it because he
said he shot it although initially he
said he didn't but we don't know whether
or not that bullet actually hit
mattingly and i think we need to know
that it's one of those loose ends that
is going to bother me hopefully we will
still see something about that brian you
know they originally said that this
trial was going to take weeks but it
seems like the pace has been picking up
i mean what can we expect for the next
week's week two
absolutely so monday they're not
expecting to have court but former
officer cosgrove is going to be in a
phone call as to whether or not he's
going to testify we expect him to plead
the fifth the same as john mattenly and
then tuesday the prosecution says they
plan to rest and the defense says
they're only going to put on brett
hankinson to testify we may see a
verdict by a week today that being next
week friday or thursday because i can't
see the jury deliberating for very long
pretty incredible and great reporting
there brian we definitely have a sense
of how the shooting definitely unfolded
we move now onto news out of california
where robert durst's murder conviction
is vacated posthumously only months
after a guilty conviction in september
of last year a california jury found
durst guilty of the 2000 death of his
best friend susan berman when durst died
in january of this year he was appealing
that conviction so according to
california state law because an appeal
was in the process of the at the time of
dirt's death the conviction has to be
vacated now durst has long been
suspected of several murders starting
with his first wife kathy mccormick
durst who went missing back in 1982
though a body has never been found kathy
was legally declared dead in 2017. then
in 2003 durst was acquitted for the
murder of his texas neighbor morris
black after prosecutors say he shot and
killed black and later dismembered his
body now following the release of the
hbo documentary the jinx durst faced a
long trial that started in 2020 it went
into 2021 this was all for the murder of
susan berman who prosecutors say durst
killed because she knew too much about
the alleged kathy durst murder durst
died in custody in january 2022 of
cardiac arrest
while robert durst is now technically
cleared of a murder conviction the real
estate heir has been suspected of
committing multiple killings over the
course of almost 40 years this week on
prime crime we take a closer look at his
case
susan berman did not let strangers in
her house she would have double locks
she wouldn't even drive over a bridge
she wouldn't talk to strangers she was
suspicious of everybody the only person
in her life which she really loved when
she stuck octagonal california was
robert durst remember this is a gunshot
wound to her head that means the killer
had to be near her she had to trust the
killer she knew her killer and since she
knew her killer and it wasn't a stranger
and there was only one person with the
motive it had to be robert durst
the first episode of the two-part prime
crime special on robert durst airs this
friday you can catch new episodes of
prime crime every friday at 5 30 and 10
30 pm eastern on the lawn crime network
still ahead on long crime daily years
after a guilty conviction scott peterson
could now be granted a new trial but
first the death of george floyd a
verdict is handed down in the federal
trial of three ex-minnesota police
officers
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
guilty across the board that's what a
federal jury in minnesota ruled on
thursday for the three ex-officers
charged in the death of george floyd
after just 13 hours of deliberation
jurors found tu tau thomas lane and jay
alexander king guilty of depriving
george floyd of his rights by showing
deliberate indifference of his medical
needs tao and king were also found
guilty for failing to intervene as
convicted killer derek chauvin knelt on
floyd's neck for now all three
defendants remain free on bond
pre-sentencing proceedings are expected
to begin next week and after the guilty
verdict was read george floyd's family
members spoke at a press conference
saying that the verdict was a step in
the right direction toward change
i smile about it and be happy but deep
down we're still hurting
you know we want this to stop you know
this means so much to us
because we've connected with so many
families
you know that's in similar situations
and receiving no justice
and
you know i'm shaking because
my first trip here the first press
conference i did i said that
we're only coming here to get some
justice and accountability
knowing today was another step towards
that
and you know it feels good
all right back to julian terry julie
i'll start with you you know we saw a
guilty verdict on all counts but now the
question is of course what's the
punishment what's the sentencing going
to be so how long could these three
defendants really face behind bars for
the federal charges so they can be
facing an extensive amount of time but
keep in mind just that they can also get
absolutely no jail time the judge is
going to view the sentencing guidelines
which can be very confusing for many
outsiders
and they're going to make it he's going
to make a determination looking at the
background of each of these defendants
and he may very well delineate the
defendants keep in mind lane is not
convicted of the same thing or all the
charges that king and tower so he may
actually
bring a lower sentence for him than he
would the others also keep in mind
there's a state case that's still
um pending right um and so they're
looking at potentially um convictions
there and serious serious uh sentences
as well well let's talk about that so
terry i'm going to you now let's talk
about those state charges aiding and
abetting what can we expect on that
front is the trial going to still happen
and how is this these convictions going
to affect it
i think we're going to hear similar
arguments jesse the aiding and abetting
the second degree murder while they were
committing this felony assault and
aiding and abetting second degree
manslaughter which means they created
this unreasonable risk but i think
you're going to see each of them say
what they said in the federal case
basically arguing tau will say you know
he was just managing the crowd king is
going to say he couldn't find a pulse he
really was trying and i think you're
going to hear lane say some of the very
same arguments he said during the
federal trial so i think we're going to
see something similar we'll see what
happens at the end of the day though
well at the end of the day their
troubles still continue switching gears
to political news where president joe
biden makes a historic scotus nomination
on friday president biden nominated
judge katanji brown jackson making her
the first black woman to be nominated
for this position this move stems from a
long time campaign promise by biden to
diversify the supreme court if the
senate confirms jackson she would be the
first former public defender to sit on
the court she would replace justice
stephen breyer who's set to retire from
the court after nearly three decades of
service right now jackson is an appeals
judge for the district of columbia
and coming up on long crime daily both
sides present closing arguments as an
ex-police captain stands trial for
murder plus a string of hearings kicked
off on friday to determine whether scott
peterson deserves a new trial our legal
analysts break down day one after this
[Music]
and welcome back everybody a juror from
the monumental gelane maxwell case will
now face questioning under oath for
accusations that he lied on a jury
questionnaire this as the one time
socialite seeks a new trial according to
maxwell's attorneys one juror who
identifies as scotty david may have lied
on his questionnaire forum by saying he
had never been sexually abused after the
verdict though he did interviews with
multiple media outlets saying that he
was sexually abused as a child now
federal judge judge allison nathan ruled
the juror will be questioned under oath
at a hearing next month maxwell's
attorneys have made their case for a new
trial but so far judge nathan has denied
that request last year maxwell was
convicted on counts of sex trafficking
for her involvement in a child sex
trafficking scandal spearheaded by the
late financier jeffrey epstein she faces
up to 65 years in prison sentencing a
set for june of this year and in
california alleged juror misconduct
could mean a new trial for convicted
killer scott peterson evidentiary
hearings for peterson began on friday in
california as defense attorneys argue
for a new trial based on
juror misconduct that claim stems from
juror 7 in peterson's 2004 trial defense
attorneys say that rachelle nice dubbed
strawberry shortcake by the media did
not disclose a past abusive relationship
while pregnant nice who took the stand
on friday was granted immunity in
exchange for her testimony nearly 20
years ago nice was part of the jury that
convicted peterson for the death of his
27 year old wife lacey and their unborn
son connor in friday's testimony nice
said she did not hold any resentment
toward peterson before or after the
trial and said that she originally
filled out the form the jury form saying
she had not been the victim of a crime
because she holds a different definition
of the word victim than what the law
defines it as now peterson was
originally sentenced to death in the
case but was later re-sentenced to life
in prison okay so julie
rochelle nice she says she doesn't hold
anything against peterson she has a
different definition of victim do you
believe her and do you think the jur the
judge is going to believe her
so i'm going to break it up so do i
believe her when she says she doesn't
have any bad feelings towards him before
the trial
i don't know that i can question that
who knows what she really thought she
didn't have any full understanding of
the the breadth of the case so i'm going
to say that i'm going to hold that in a
band in terms of whether or not she
believed she was the victim of a crime i
don't think there's any question that
anyone
who reviewed anything that she had said
in the past in regards and filled out
would regard her as not being a victim
she knew when she was filling it out
that she was trying to get an order of
protection that she was scared that she
was scared for her potential child so i
i don't buy it i don't think the judge
will buy it but that doesn't mean it's
going to result in a new trial well
julie's skeptical let's live in a world
terry where we just hypothetically he
gets a new trial what can we expect to
see there i mean could he be acquitted
could he get a new could he be convicted
you know go free
well i think there is a decent chance he
is going to get a new trial jury
misconduct is a very serious allegation
first we know the death sentence was
overturned now he may get this new trial
the defense has already signaled jesse
that they have new evidence they're
saying that they can prove that there
were burglars in the neighborhood that
maybe they were the ones who caused this
death they're saying they have witnesses
who saw that she was alive that day so
if that in fact is true we could see
some new evidence and i'm sure the
prosecution is going to push hard if
there's a new trial i can't believe
scott peterson's name is back in the
news but that is the reality of it so
we'll see what happens there when we
come back we head to florida for closing
arguments from both sides still ahead
the murder trial of ex-police officer
curtis reeves
and welcome back to long crime delay
everybody prosecutors and defense
attorneys presented their closing
arguments to a florida jury on friday in
the trial of retired police captain
curtis reeves who's charged with
second-degree murder for shooting and
killing a man inside a movie theater in
2014. testimony wrapped up thursday with
the defendant taking the stand telling
jurors he feared for his life the day he
shot and killed chad olson reeves
testified saying he figured it was the
quote end of the line for me when he
says that olson was coming at him full
of rage on the day of the shooting reid
said reeves had become frustrated over
olson being on his cell phone during
movie previews the two got into an
argument popcorn was thrown and reeves
has said that olson threw a cell phone
at him which he says prompted him to
shoot olson in self-defense assistant
state attorney scott rosenwasser told
the jury they shouldn't buy his story
the defendant wants you to believe this
a retired captain from the tampa police
department who's been involved in
robbery homicide
fugitives
the special weapons and tactics team
also known as swat
remember during his testimony what he's
saying man it's eye-opening when i first
started the level of violence and the
dangerousness you wouldn't believe it
yet that very same person wants you to
believe that in all his years doing all
those jobs throughout
tampa
the one person that scared him the very
most
the one person that he had to shoot and
kill was in theater number 10 on january
13th 2014. the person that scared them
the most is a father and a husband that
said leave me alone i'm texting my
daughter maybe he threw an f-bomb in
there
now reeves defense attorney told the
jury in their closing argument that an
expert witness proved reeve's reaction
was a justifiable use of force against
olsen
his theme
his primary theme that he came up here
he said ladies and gentlemen the jury
this is about a man that shot another
man over popcorn
their expert witness roy bedard got up
here and under oath said
absolutely not
0.72
seconds
between that period
of those hands coming
to grab that popcorn
and the firing of the shot
remember roy the dog said there's an
action and a reaction
the human body takes time
to perceive what you're seeing
to decide what you're going to do
from that act
and then to carry out the act
0.72 seconds in possible
julie as i watched it i still wonder do
you think it helped to hurt reeves to
take the stand in his own defense at the
end of the day
so it's a great question look he didn't
have to testify because a lot of what he
already had said came in on the
prosecution case i think maybe it was
somewhat of a hail mary hoping that he
can tell the jury once again and get the
jury to maybe get to know him feel
sympathy for him to maybe get one or two
jurors to buy what he's selling i don't
think um he's going to be successful in
the end i don't see the self-defense but
maybe he can get a couple jurors on his
side terry we had some passionate
closing arguments on both sides who do
you think delivered a stronger closing
how do you see the outcome here
i absolutely think that the prosecution
did a stronger closing statement and i
think the defense also did a good job
he's very
lively but i i think at the end of the
day i agree with julie that the
prosecution is going to prevail they
started out saying
man killed over popcorn toss imagine
that in the newspapers and when you
think about it it is so frivolous
someone died because of that one of the
things the prosecution said was three
witnesses heard the defendant say
throw popcorn in my face
and basically you know that that's
something that is just privileged so i
think at the end of the day the
prosecution is going to definitely
prevail here there was no reason for
that shooting terry i'm going to go back
to you on this you don't think the
defense made some strong points here
like we just heard their own witness you
know they're experts saying this is
self-defense i mean if you think about
it is it not possible that chad olson
might have struck this defendant this
defendant who's older in age
i actually think the defense lost when
he said how quickly the defendant
responded even if a phone had been
thrown in his face look the defense
started out by saying you don't judge a
person until you've walked in their
shoes well all of us have walked in
those shoes if popcorn gets thrown at us
or even a phone you don't shoot somebody
to death all right well we'll wait and
see julie terry thank you so much
everyone out there thanks for joining us
here on long crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you